hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the 2018 Greinke chess classic here
we have a game between Georg Meier and
Magnus Carlsen and I'm very happy to be
able to show you this game as its it's
an extremely interesting game and you'll
really understand what they mean by the
old saying the most beautiful part of a
chess game is a rarely seen so let's
let's just check a couple of photos
before we before we dive into the game
here we have a nice close-up of the
audience that is observing the games
here a nice close-up of Magnus Carlsen
probably writing down the first move
here we have well it's not a close-up of
Gehrig Meier and one other thing you
have to you have to notice here as is
that it's it's a it's a front shot of
guruma but it's actually Magnus Carlsen
that's in the focus so that's that's
what happens when you're a world
champion even when you're not being
recorded directly you're still in the
focus so here we have a nice photo of
caution and Vishwanathan Anand taking
taking a nice walk relaxing from their
games and those are the photos from from
this round I do hope you enjoy that now
let's check out the game Meier opens
with d4 now we have Knight to f6 c4 e6
and the Knight to f3 so the antonyms od5
g3 Bishop to b4 the standard maneuver
Bishop d2 Bishop back to e7 Bishop to g2
and we have castles castles Knight bt7
Queen to c2 c6 Bishop to f4 Knight to e4
h for now Knight B to f6 Knight B to d2
Knight captures Knight captures and now
Knight to h5 the only good Square for
the bishop is e3 so Bushra back to e3
and now f5 f5 an excellent move that
might be preparing some expansion on the
Kings side later on also this rook might
be able to come into the game and also
and most importantly creating a nice
outpost on e4 for this night that is
currently on h5
so Bishop to f3 attacking the knight
quint we ate defending the item h5 and
now Bishop to g5 and here at Carlson
place tonight back to f6 preparing 90 to
e4 at some point an interesting idea is
definitely Bishop captures an g5h
captures and Queen to g6 with the idea
that you want to capture the g5 pawn but
after Bishop captures Queen captures and
the Knight captures you are defending
the g5 pawn and after black plays f4
which is kind of the whole idea of this
maneuver than white defense which came
to g2 and now white is perfectly fine
even much better as the rook is now
coming to h1 it will be very dangerous
for black so after Bishop to g5 Knight
back to f6 we have III and now b6 rook 8
2 c1 and the bishop to a6 and there is
no official interview with Carlsen after
this game but you can check out the the
entire coverage of round 5 and then you
can fast forward to the end of the
coverage there you can see a kind of an
interview with Magnus Carlsen where he
says that he's not very satisfied with
this Bishop to a sex move it he could
have tried for something better
he mentions Knight to e4 the idea being
that after Bishop captures Queen
captures C captures and C captures white
it doesn't really have the option of
exploiting the C file as the knight on V
2 is undefended and if Knight captures F
captures you move the bishop now rook
comes to f7 again and there is no way
for white to infiltrate on the C file
the bishop can be developed in black and
even double rooks and the F file so all
is well here but okay in the game Bishop
to e6 by Carlsen a3 now Knight comes to
e4 Bishop captures on e7 Queen captures
on e7 and the bishop back to e2 and here
across and plays a bush should be back
to b7 waiting to see what happens before
by Meier rook a to c8 and now C v e5 by
Carson trying to bust open the center
d captures on e5 Queen captures 95 and
Knight captures on e 4f captures on e4
and now Queen to c3
here Meier offers a trade of Queens
Queen to a5 cost and the clients
yes he does have a lot of pressure on da
file also Queen to h3 might be an idea
in some lines here we have a for and
here Carlson as he calls it after the
game plays g5 and he calls this a big
Bluff
the idea is there really is there really
is no danger here for white in the game
H capture Sun g5 was played but even
possible was f4 f4 because Queen to h3
doesn't give black anything there's no
real threat of Queen captures on g3
because the white that defends perfectly
well with rook to f2 and now if you
capture it you get a roof to g2 Queen
captures and now rook captures on g5 and
black and white black is lost king f7
now rook comes to g7 with check King
moves Queen e5 check King moves Queen d6
check King moves and now Queen to d7
this is checkmate it's not not an
entirely forced line but a lot of things
can go wrong
so after g5 Maher played H captures and
g5 Queen captures on g5 and now King to
g2 now preparing to bring the rook over
to the H file rook to c7 Carson prepares
to bring the other look into the game
rope to h1 and now rook to g7 a very
deadly and poisonous move by Carlsen if
Maher isn't careful now for example if
he plays something like C captures on b6
what ideas of creating a passed pawn
then he's actually getting checkmated
it's a force checkmate in eight moves
with rook captures this comes with check
king capture squink after some g3 King
f1 and now rook to f7 the king has
nowhere to go
Bishop to f3 you have to block rook
captures King to e2 rook F to check King
Jiwon now open a discussion form the
queen or okay to check King moves and
now Queen f3 King you want and the Queen
captures on h1 with a very nice
checkmate so after g7 are up to g7
admire defensive look to g1 and we have
Queen to f5 rook to f1 defending the f2
pawn and now Bishop to a6 and here it's
a again a deadly idea by Carlsen idea is
if you capture the bishop then
when to have three go into f3 and black
who wins the game it's a forced
checkmate in seven moves King to h7 if
you go if you go King King to h2 if you
go King to G 1 and then rook captures on
g3 will be winning
so King to h2 and now Rock the g6 a
threatening look to h6 followed by rook
captures on h1 only defense is Bishop to
see it and now it doesn't matter root 2
H 6 Bush rubber blocks and now rook
captures on h3 King captures and now
rook to f5 and there is no defense
against against a rock to h5 so a very
nice idea by Carlsen
but after Bishop day 6 of course Meier
is not gonna fall for this and mark
plays a brilliant move of his own he
plays b5 b5 with the idea of preventing
this distinction between the two bishops
for one move
Carlson plays seek after some b5 and now
that this tension is no longer here he
uses this chance to bring his rock into
the game rook to h5 with an attack on
the Queen Queen to f7 by Carlsen and now
Queen to e5 Bishop to b7 as you don't
want you can't really capture the point
here but should be saying again a6 you
don't really have any moves so Bishop to
b7 and here C captures on b6 we have be
captured on a4 and the B captures on a 7
so Carson now has a passed pawn on a 4
but Maher has a passed pawn on a 7 and
here Bishop to a it costs and blocks the
pawn and here rook to g5 by Meier rope
to g5 is actually a winning move for
white but when he played admire didn't
know it was a winning mo he felt it was
a very strong move and he played it
because he wanted Carlsen to capture the
a 7 point the problem is if you captured
the rook capturing the rook also doesn't
really work for black because Queen
captures with Czech Queen blocks Queen
capture screen captures and now rook to
a1 simply going for that pawn and then
you have a passed pawn and a7 and in the
room behind it so Bishop to c6 defending
it but now rook to c1 attacking the
bishop and here you don't
have a good move you can't go Bishop to
b7 simply rook to c7 we'll check the
King and pick up the bishop if you try
any other ideas for example rook rook to
c8 then simply rook captures on c6 after
who captures you promote to a queen and
after the most obvious Bishop to a8 and
now simply getting the bishop out of the
way and also blocking the pawn then
rooked the c5 with rook to a5 coming
winning the pawn and then it's simply a
one position
so after up to g5 cotton played Queen
captures on a7 and here comes the move
that Carlsen missed a brilliant move by
Georg Meier and the only move that
actually gives white the advantage
Bishop to g4 Bishop to g4 and now black
really doesn't have a move
the idea is after a fluke captures then
Bishop to e6 wins the game you have to
block now comes Queen captures and after
King moves now rook to c1 and there is
no good defense against roof to c8 if
you play Bishop to b7 simply stopping at
the den Bishop captures on f7 wins your
Europe a whole rook if you capture the
bishop then you're getting checkmated
here Queen to f6 checkmate so after
Bishop to g4 across and has to find a
move he plays King to h8 definitely
definitely an idea but it doesn't work
it did work in this case because Maher
was so long time that in the game I
replayed rook to e1 he decided to go
grab grab his past pawn and exchange all
the pieces here
so this is how the game went on rook to
a1 cross and played Queen to e7 and here
we have Queen captures on g7 with Czech
Queen captures rook captures King
captures and after rook captures na for
Bishop to c6 and rook to before was
played and here in this position they
agree to a draw it's a slightly better
position for white white she does have
three only one pawn island the pawns are
on dark squares and he does have a light
square bishop but there's no real way to
make progress here but let's return to
this position after King to h8 instead
of rope to a-1 which Maher played as he
he didn't find anything else
this is actually a completely winning
position for white and white has a
couple of ways to actually win this
position so one of the ways white can
win is rook to h5 rook to hy5 f5 is
completely winning and the black doesn't
have a good way to prevent this if you
try Queen to e7 or Queen to f7 let's try
Queen to f7 you get rook captures on h7
and there is no defense
the rock is pinned you can't you can't
do anything here if you capture the rock
then comes rook to h1 King moves to g6
and now Bishop to h5 simply simply
winning if you don't if you go if you go
King to g8 then Bishop three six you win
the Queen and the game buddy acting g6
Bishop checks King moves and our Bishop
captures on f7 this is checkmate so this
is one way to do it
another thing after King to h8 even a
rook to h1 is winning you don't have to
play rook to h5 idea being that Queen to
e7 now offering a trade of Queens again
rook captures on h7 King captures and
now rook to h5 check and both Carson and
Meyer said that they saw this position
and they couldn't find anything okay you
don't do you're not gonna go King to Jay
King to g8 to allow Bishop to e6 but
both of them saw King to g6 and they
agreed that there's nothing for white
here to do but actually here I'm sure
you all can see it now that you know
that there is something I feel free to
pause the video and find the winning
move for white that both Carlson and
Meyer missed so I will give a couple of
seconds although I'm pretty sure now all
of you can see it the move both of them
missed is rook to h6 and after this you
would have a brilliant victory against
the world's champion
point being that if you capture it Queen
to h5 is immediate checkmate and if you
don't capture it if you go to f7 then
you get Queen to h5 check King to g8 and
of course rook to 88 checkmate
so although it seems pretty obvious it's
really not since both girl Meier and
Magnus Carlsen the reigning world
champion missed it
okay albeit they were both in time
trouble but you know such a shame
such a shame for Gehrig Meier missing an
opportunity like this the checkmate a
world champion Magnus Carlsen so yeah
this is the position once again Rock day
one was played but rook to h1 or rock to
h5 both both win the game like
immediately so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it
well I'm sure he didn't to enjoy rook to
e1 but as they say the most beautiful
part of a chess game is very rarely seen
over the board so yeah I would like to
thank Ragavendra but bus Ragavendra
bastard john behringer and knew their
net for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video thank you for watching and I will
see you soon with another interesting
game oh yeah and of course I always
forgot here are the results after round
5 so things didn't really change all of
the games from round 5 were drawn
Khurana still in first place watch here
Maximus your autograph in second video
of in third all of them with three and a
half and then with three points Aragon
and Carlson then honored and blue bond
with two and - Maya girl and night each
fkd with one and a half point and yeah
ok one other thing I wanted to tell you
I did I did order this additional red
light to improve with my with my video
quality as I do have like this huge
window behind me so sometimes it's
really problematic with the lights and
then when it finally arrived I realized
that it actually comes without a battery
included so I kind of felt like an idiot
but you know it happens so if you're
gonna order some additional wet lighting
for yourself or maybe for something you
do do check that it comes with a battery
included so yeah
that's it thank you all and I will see
you soon